I let the Bombardier it's a busy [ __ ]
Monday today you ain't got time for fun
and games
it's Monday we're coming out the box you
could see us you can hear a sound for
blocks and blocks
but the rest is up to you you can't
suckers
[Music]
and just like that the clouds part to
show you the true color of the [ __ ]
sky it's all about mundane [ __ ]
uncle Joey here wishing you all a
[ __ ] great Monday but remember it's
just not that easy you just don't wake
up and go outside this little [ __ ]
note with a buried treasure
you got a dig [ __ ] you gotta get in
there you gotta roll up your [ __ ]
sleeves you gotta shine your shoes you
got a powder your balls you gotta feel
good from the inside first then the
outside and then you're ready to take
these [ __ ] down like hostages
you understand me
we're the church or what's happening now
when I gotta show up with Hassan he's in
a nice video for you cuz I wish it was
that [ __ ] easy out there
these [ __ ] are playing for keeps you
got to be prepared you got to take a
shower you gotta eat your cereal you
gotta have your oatmeal plus to fight
them in a bet right here once this gets
into your [ __ ] brain waves with the
[ __ ] uncle joy mentality the aka
immigrant mentality - aka the cops are
looking for me let me tell you something
who the [ __ ] is gonna stop me
[ __ ]
[Music]
Oh Cinco DeMayo weekend Mexican gets a
check on a Friday you don't feel until
Sunday aha
it's going down Tempe Arizona I'll be
there the Tempe improv Thursday Friday
and Saturday night
Stone - the [ __ ] diesels they are
[ __ ] I got cartel members jumping
fences and [ __ ] right now just to bring
me special edibles from [ __ ] a couple
different cartel members don't worry
about nothing no names bust the guy
kidnapped is showing up cat Vela after
30 year he's coming out of the [ __ ]
cave and giving me a hug and [ __ ] what
am i smoking could have smokin debt from
sunset herbal [ __ ] Obama every time I
smoke this [ __ ] I think about black
people I think about mrs. Obama I wanna
eat her [ __ ] little monkey huh I
whipped that [ __ ] Chinese hair right
off her head there's three [ __ ] dead
Chinese people walking around right now
I'm saying what the [ __ ] happened to my
hair mr. Obama's and [ __ ] ass real
waving at people will the [ __ ] thing
i'ma show up for bad weed the [ __ ]
bad joke this is uncle Joey [ __ ] you
understand me
I'm with you you're with me and they
want to be with us why because we got
what it takes balls and [ __ ] heart
and we don't give a [ __ ] you understand
me
anyway look the helicopters out even
watching me since 6:30 in the morning
[ __ ] him what's he gonna do to me send a
laser beam down here [ __ ] him
hey man jeff sessions is [ __ ] boy
watching
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah look at that listen I'm setting
you house play like a father sang this
son your father me I'm looking in the
eye and I'm telling you don't [ __ ]
around today
don't let him [ __ ] with you and don't
let nobody [ __ ] do dick you
understand they touch you in the [ __ ]
neck you stabbed in the [ __ ] stomach
you follow me don't take nothing from
nobody today today's your [ __ ] day
you dream of days like today that the
world by the balls it's right here
throw a little [ __ ] reefer pad on and
get the mindfuck and kicking and then go
out there and let these [ __ ]
know you ain't [ __ ] around today you
did that already you did that it yeah
I'm having a great time him with you six
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here
it's time to set the herb man free
that's what it's time for [ __ ]
so I don't really give a [ __ ] what you
think of me or whatever at least I'm out
here trying I'm going to work today I'm
a [ __ ] TV show how's that one for you
today and tomorrow I'll be incognito you
can't get holding them on the set
minding my own business
talking of [ __ ] white people but
scoop of [ __ ] ha ha ha ha
I also enjoy the keto diet in all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] but I'll be back
Wednesday ready a sling dick and then
I'm on my way that can't be Arizona for
the improper been playing this is 90
[ __ ] 8 I loved that place I got all
the room I got the room down that's my
room they want me to play that stand-up
live that [ __ ] Museum over there's
Phoenix [ __ ] you I'm a Tempe boy from
[ __ ] 84 you follow me I was back in
Tempe an eighties for smoking [ __ ]
mushrooms and peepees with Indians you
ever do that no I'm gonna [ __ ] you think
you're dealing with here but anyway
enjoy which with the [ __ ] here beat
no it beat I'm joining just joining into
the party it's 7:31 in the morning who
[ __ ] hitch up to smoke a bowl these
days nobody I'll be scared I'm micro
dose at about 11:00 here Micro toast my
dick but throw a smoke and he Pia you
understand Pete
there's the [ __ ] that use [ __ ] smoke
before they went and picked up Jesus on
[ __ ] Good Friday this is the same
week anyway analogous a little [ __ ] up
this mother who cares the [ __ ] we pay
attention to them and they take home you
gotta live your life be who gives a [ __ ]
I love your [ __ ] have a
phenomenal day you know you uncle Joey
loves you I've cast for up I got another
one coming down on Wednesday morning and
you know I got your back some of them
are good some of them are bad I'm there
to deliver
that's the his most important point you
could count on your [ __ ] uncle Joey
did not like the other uncle's they
finger-banging and they create to the
[ __ ] toy school me I'm as solid as the
Rock of Gibraltar I love you
[ __ ] have a grid a great day
and we'll be back this week the [ __ ] you
ready Amanda man on break the hombre and
I can't come back about life and the
many other things that affect it I love
you [ __ ] don't let nobody
[ __ ] with you and I remember always
win the [ __ ] high battle
don't take your eyeballs off them so
they know that they you watch their
little Souls [ __ ] week and if you
keep eye beaming them to death in my
just sucking dick that happens I love
you guys have a great day